plusieurs fois des gens qui sont venus
cagoulés et armés chez mes parents c'est
enfin moi je le sais ses pleurs fois
arrivé il ya plusieurs fois des voitures
qui font la ronde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux jeunes tik tok heures benjamins les
digues et quid paul ont voulu faire le
buzz en se déhanchant encre octobre dans
une église
conques millions de vu la vidéo wii 40
millions de vues on va la revoir sans le
récap merci benjamin d'être avec nous
influenceurs et merci alexandre bigot
vous êtes l'avocat de benjamin non on
était tous les deux
devant une église et ouais je pense
qu'on avait besoin d'eux où je prends
voulait rigoler tous les deux y'avait
pas de préparation où les rigoler faire
cette vidéo dans les rigoles et il y
avait un pas le message derrière il ya
tant de base et s'était même temps la
poste de base tout juste on va danser
dans l'église ont fait la vidéo c'était
super légers vous étiez seul nom si on
était seuls n'avait pas la musique
surtout dénoncer l'homophobie cch gt ça
représente dans la libye soit d'accord
alors que gillis est depuis devenu une
histoire compliquée en plus je voulais
venir vu venir témoigner en pour autre
chose vous reviendra certainement d'en
parler parce que c'est c'est un triste
sujet juste touché par ce garçon parce
que il faut comprendre quelque chose
c'est que bien sûr c'est extrêmement
choquant mais derrière tout ça est
derrière de deux gamins qu'on compte
peut-être fait une bêtise il ya un petit
message entendre qui est bien sûr de ne
pas critiquer avec l'église catholique
et jamais de la vie mais qui est que
comme vous dire que moi je suis
catholique et comme ce garçon j'ai les
mêmes sexualité pendant jusqu'à quelques
la profession de foi pendant 15 ans on
vous dit tous les jours tous les jours
qu'être homosexuel c'est mal que vous
êtes rejeter que vous ne serez pas dans
la maison de dieu qui vous ferment à la
porte que vous ne pourrez jamais vous
marier à l'époque c'est tout ce que vous
entendez et pendant quinze d'un temps
vous dit tu es quelqu'un de mal tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps alors
ça avance un petit peu ça avance
doucement moi il m'a fallu près 40 ans
pour deux pour accepter le fait d'être
catholique donc oui ils sont jeunes je
tombe très touchant ce garçon alors bien
sûr c'est très maladroit il dit que des
substances tout ça mais je pense qu'il
faut peut-être aller un petit pot de au
dollar voilà donc je pense que vous ne
rendez mais alors absolument pas service
à votre communauté et le montage est
entièrement france est vraiment c'est un
petit cesse ses ratés excusez moi mais
c'est vraiment raté si un message et
j'en suis même pas sûr que quand on voit
votre appui sur les avec les jambes des
gens qui vous aiment
le jeu l'alcool le sexe les écrans les
addictions sont nombreuses et
dangereuses n'est ce pas daniel
pour ses addictions et ses dépendances
le plus dur et parfois de les voir de
les reconnaître avant de les soigner
chez haji que je vaux si j'étais un peu
quand j'étais très jeune mais pas ce qui
m'est arrivé ce qui avait de pire quand
on joue c'est que j'ai gagné tout de
suite et après j'étais en fac et jallet
effectivement au casino dans le temps en
cachette dirait qu'on commence avant que
ses chaussures commence avant de
l'ordinateur on commence avant tout
c'est tout à fait vrai que je me suis un
peu je me suis un peu mis dans la merde
mais après je me suis arrêté j'ai pas
pourquoi j'ai de temps vous êtes
retrouvée qu'avec vos yeux pour pleurer
alors j'ai le temps d'en addictives à
tout mais j'ai un instinct de survie
il ya ce tempérament on a tous un
tempérament s'arrête accrochés aux
choses mais il ya des gens qui ont des
facteurs de protection donc c'est à dire
qu'ils tombent pas dans l'addiction il
était toujours au bord du précipice mais
je n'avais plus
irak six mois j'ai perdu en une fois
ouais
beaucoup d'argent
ça cent mille euros en une soirée une
soirée oui ça monte carlo voilà
et c'est très difficile - il m'a fallu
trois fois pour m'en sortir masque
humain sauver c'est la foi et l'amour
d'accord alors mais c'est vrai que c'est
une maladie
prend en fait sa petite fille vous allez
dire de toute façon d'aller bosser dans
moment c'est à dire vous vous buviez
combien combien par un par jour un
moment ah bah moi je me réveillais le
matin c'était le rhum à tige el hawa
directs et indirects hospitalisés les
gens me mais ce qui nous plonge pas
après plusieurs planches et derrière
c'est ça c'est que hospitalisés les gens
pour les désintoxiquer tout seul ça sert
à rien il faut qu'ils aient derrière un
programme de soins continus et moi je
dis aux patients aux patientes quant à
rendement ou iran dans mon bureau c'est
vous avez maintenant on verra dans un an
ce qui se passe et on va vous suivre
régulièrement
je voudrais m'excuser toutes les
personnes que j'ai pu blesser je m'en
suis pas rendu compte sur le coup
benjamin as tu lis par quatre cent mille
personnes votre compte a été désactivé
suite à cette vidéo vous n'êtes plus
d'unions gagner de l'argent en vendant
des photos de vous dénuder sur mym c'est
ça voilà on en parle
depuis sa vidéo dans l'église il a été
menacé de mort et même de décapitations
et ce soir ils voudraient nous parler
parce qu'il skie sais pas qu'est ce qui
s'est passé chez vos parents il ya
plusieurs fois des gens qui sont venus
cagoulés et armés chez mes parents
c'était enfin moi je le sais cette fleur
fois arrivé il ya plusieurs fois des
voitures qui font la ronde je vois des
gens qui viennent devant les
explications des parents enfin oui ça
arrive tous les jours aujourd'hui ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que je suis
venu aujourd'hui seuls mais pour être
sincère et le plus honnête et le plus
indépendant possible
et je veux aussi revenir sur ce que j'ai
dit du coup il ya c'était vendredi je
suis humain je suis venu la raison pour
laquelle j'ai posté cette vidéo et/ou
que les fêtes ou quoi c'était pas pour
combattre les préceptes de l'homophobie
comme je l'avais dit c'était pas vrai
la vérité c'est que c'est une bêtise je
les fait consciemment cette bêtise c'est
le fait qu'il y ait des gens qui
viennent chez mes parents le fait qu'ils
les gens qui me suivent dans la rue le
fait qu'ils les gens qui veulent me tuer
tous les sacs ok comme vous l'avez g20 a
échoué mais
c'est un truc 100% être ok et avoir
défendu son ok comme vous l'avez fait
vous c'est défendre le fait que oui on
peut tuer quelqu'un toi tu vas pas nous
faire la morale non plus quand même
plus marrant et le reste par le rabat
estime que pour nous ça nous peine moi
c'est de la peine que j'ai reçu ça me
fait du mal de voir ça franchement c'est
comme si j'allais nantes et toi c'est
comme si j'allais dans un lieu que
j'allais chez pas dans ta chambre
d'enfants sous sur la tombe d'un de tes
proches etc et que je faisais c'était un
truc comme ça
alors si vous habitez dans une agonie
sur une mosquée ça m'aurait plus mis en
colère pour le coup parce que ça mange
moins peiné puisque forcément c'est
moins sacré pour moi mais par contre
j'aurais trouvé ça dégueulasse tout
autant si c'est pas nul de faire ça je
pense que il ya beaucoup de français qui
pensent qu'en fait juste ton père qui
devrait être mettre une tarte et te dire
arrête dandiner et va travailler parce
qu'en gros c'est ça là on est en train
de parler et des millions de français
sont en train de parler d'un truc en
fait c'est une connerie de gamins qui
est qui karim
est maintenant là on est en train
d'inverser le tri dans le bon signe
leurs moyens cette excuse moi daniel
mais moi j'étais super choqué parce que
moi je suis croyante aussi comme toi et
moi ces images je m'en fous que ça me
choque pas en fait il faut pas mettre la
religion c'est pas c'est pas sacré c'est
pas au dessus tout la religion c'est la
religion cette affaire intime c'est
affaire privée tu vas pas aller dans une
église parce qu'il a mis un crypto que
tu as dis oh là là quelle horreur il a
mis dans un crop top il ya mi octobre
c'est dégueulasse non en fait on s'en
fout ta religion c'est un truc privé
c'est un truc intime moi ça va pas
ébranler ma foi ou pas ma foi donc je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui en faisant ça on
s'attend qu'à à son en s'attaquant à
benjamin finalement on le fragilise et
je pense que ça montre que justement
aujourd'hui notre société elle est
pourri parce qu'on donne justement la
parole aux intégristes j'arrive
difficilement à concevoir qu'on puisse
est blessé parce que moi j'étais aussi
négligent quand j'ai 18 ans enfin
continuer votre vie allez allez allez
prier dans votre église et continuer à
croire en ce que vous croyez jeu c'est
génial et c'est hyper bien défendre et
le camp vous le défendez vous négligez
fait de la merde enfin franchement c'est
comme ça le problème est le mal m6 avait
agi 10 ma foi le problème c'est que mais
en fait c'est toujours la même chose
c'est comme si j'allais sur la tombe
d'un de vos proches que je dansais
dessus je faisais du toit et que quand
vous me disiez que ces anglais cherche
ça fragilise pas votre deuil et bien sûr
un four ça vous ferait du mal c'est
évident c'est un lieu pour nous c'est un
exemple de baptiste et votons jeu tu
regrettes tu es ce que tu es ce que si
aujourd'hui non je capte pas cela pas
battu referait la même vidéo sinon si tu
savais tout ce qui se passait derrière
theuriau ferait la même vidéo j'ai brisé
une question c'est à dire que la nature
on te dit voilà il va se passer tout ça
derrière tu referait la même vidéo
d'aucuns regrettent que c'est parce que
j'ai peur
[Musique]
il avait été pointé du doigt comme étant
le noir derrière zemmour au moment du
meeting de villepinte jeu serré que
j'aime parce que je suis en accord avec
ses idées et avec le constat qu'il
dresse concernant la situation de la
france depuis plusieurs années depuis
son engagement aux côtés d'eric zemmour
tanguy david 18 ans est victime tous les
jours d'insultés de menaces racistes
aperçu des menaces de mort
très rapidement être interpellé par la
police et une enquête a été ouverte pour
violences en réunion et injures
publiques en raison de la race est ce
soit en guy david et réagi à cette
agression doté pmp
merci tanguay david être avec nous ce
soir militant reconquête étudiants en
licence de droit à qu'on vous étiez venu
nous voir sur le plateau pour nous dire
votre soutien à eric zemmour vous le
soutenez toujours toujours évidemment a
toujours toujours à vents et marées
bonjour toujours d'accord vous y croyez
oui ah oui mais non ah oui
khalid quand quand ce jeune homme vous
dit pourquoi tu fais ça c'est quoi
pourquoi tu fais ça pourquoi tout
soutien à zemmour 5 comment donc comment
ça c'est pas si vous êtes sur les champs
d'idées ouais c'est ça je viendrai
j'étais seul ce moment là je sortais
d'une soirée d'une autre soirée voilà
j'allais boire un verre fera un dernier
verre voilà un truc comme ça et si vous
voulez que dans un café donc que sur les
champs et le gérant me dit je crois
qu'il ya du monde qui vous attend devant
et c'est alors je vois bien aussi qu'il
y avait une bande aussi lac était devant
enfin voilà qui m'attendait etc qui
réclamaient que je sorte donc j'ai
patienté pendant 20 minutes derrière le
café le temps d'appeler mon humeur
nature arrive c'est rapidement mais il
était au courant je l'avais télé j avais
téléphoné pour lui dire je vais arriver
rapidement faudrait qu'on strapontin
constat est aussitôt parce qu'il ya des
gens qui nous attendons donc voilà
revenu quand même comment il est venu
quand elle est venue quand même il était
à côté donc voilà je sors aussitôt
j'entends les fils de [ __ ] il a chopé le
etc ça voilà des termes très bon voilà
je monte dans la voiture et puis c'est
alors qu'une bande de sauvages saute sur
la voiture tape dessus etc crache dessus
enfin tout ce que vous voulez et
jusqu'au moment où ils finissent par
ouvrir la portière de force et me sera
me donne des coups de poing des coups de
pièces que vous voulez me crachent je
n'avais peur maintenant de soutenir non
produit tout au contraire non pas du
tout non au contraire je même le
soutenir encore plus non non pas du tout
non non
moi je sais pas une bande de sauvages et
draka et qui va m'effrayer voilà
d'accord
ils sont contents ils ont fait les
malins on s'entend sur une voiture et en
faisant peur aussi aux chauffeurs etc
c'est vrai que c'est c'est très
intelligent voilà mais c'est pas pour
autant que je vais arrêter de soutenir
est mort bien au contraire énormément je
vous dis de de musulmans et je les dis
encore à la dernière fois qu'ils qui
soutiennent pas du tout eric zemmour
mais qui sont quittes type qui
l'écoutent et qui sont choqués par ce
qu'ils nient et qui se disent nous à
cause de lui aussi ont subi beaucoup de
d'actes racistes et ont subi dans
autonome dans nos métiers respectifs des
choses qu'on subissait pas avant qui
sous leur répondais mais eric zemmour
n'est pas l'origine de cette
hystérisation du débat qu'on voit en
politique depuis quelques années en
france eric zemmour selon moi soulève
des thématiques et des problèmes qui
sont importants et voilà il ya des
problèmes qui sont là qui sont en place
depuis longtemps et je pense qu'eric
zemmour est la solution à ce problème
vous comprenez pas les gens qui sont
insultés nom produisent ou pas du tout
bah oui je dirais que bande de sauvages
la granulation raciste non non non
c'était alors oui pour moi non plus une
question malgré un taux faut quand même
rappeler une chose c'est qu'en 2011 eric
zemmour a été condamné pour avoir dit
que la plupart des trafiquants étaient
des noirs et des arabes qu'est ce que
vous en pensez de ça parce que vous avez
déposé plainte pour injures raciales
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez par
rapport à cette condamnation tombe à ce
très simple moi je pense qu'eric zemmour
été condamné pour délit d'opinion une
vie des choses qui dérangent beaucoup
mais je ne crois pas qu'il ait dire
seulement - un mensonge attend toujours
la réaction de sos racisme vous savez
qui apparemment défend le racisme je ne
savais pas mais ces rixes et
il va le faire je suis pas et on attend
dé notre conquête catabase
il arrive là dessus là tu tombes y
arrivons désormais je veux dire on
attend toujours ses belles personnes
anti racistes etc c'est apparemment qui
ne sont jamais là quand il s'agit de moi
voilà quand certains militants d'eric
zemmour évidemment tout est permis de
lui cracher sur la tronche de le
tabasser et c'est là on n'entend pas de
lutte voilà c'est du racisme etc non
silence radio c'est étonnant donc quand
vous prenez dans la rue vous allez vous
allez - sortie on vous allez faire quoi
déjà je ne sors plus seul ça m'arrivait
encore quelques fois maintenant je le
fais plus mais voilà je sors toujours
avec vous avez des amis qui vous ont
tourné le dos depuis que vous non enfin
où il y en a quelques-uns mais j'ai
demandé à l'un face à des amis du coup
et
le paris saint germain est donc l'émir
du qatar et celle du tout pour le tout
et donc aurait proposé ce contrat sur
deux ans 120 millions d'euros donc c'est
64 5 millions d'euros par an ça fait
donc un million deux cent mille euros
par semaine et ça fait donc 118 euros
par minute mais c'est vrai que ce serait
le plus gros salaires de tous les temps
oui c'est un peu gros salaires de tous
les temps alors ça devient une affaire
d'état est à au qatar parce que l'émir
du qatar veut le garder et à en france
parce qu'on dit qu emmanuel macron way
l'aurait rencontré et lui aurait demandé
de rester au nom de la france la france
a besoin de vous et nicolas sarkozy
grange supporters du psg lui aussi fait
pression sur lui il paraît même que
valérie pécresse l'aurait fait voter
voter aux primaires
alors le real madrid real madrid lui
proposait une prime à la signature parce
qu'il est libre de signer de 50 millions
d'euros directement et un salaire de 25
millions sur six ans 150 donc ce package
le qatar est en train de le dépasser en
lui proposant de rester il tente le tout
pour le tout avec une cata pardon mais
qu'est ce qui est choquant c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde a bien sûr du
monde son pilote essayeur 45 millions
d'euros par an et c'est exactement le
même salaire 1 me en europe à coeur mais
c'est le meilleur joueur du fc bâle et
point barre il marque il est l'un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde vous êtes le
meilleur joueur de france en animateur
vous regardez je suis pas tout à fait à
ce
n'est pas vraiment le décès de la chaîne
non non pas du tout moi je suis
d'auxerre
le real proposerait 50 millions d'euros
par an de salaire annuel à killian mbp
et le psg lui proposerait 62,4 millions
d'euros par an c'est à dire et à une
broutille de 12 millions can en battant
rien pour lui proposer son acheter tu
fais pour acheter des mocassins
appris à des enjeux sportifs aussi pour
lui bien sûr année prochaine je pense
que c'est pas l'argent moi je sais pas
pourquoi je sens qu'ils sont qu'ils
veulent ce sens qu'il va rester ce
serait bien qu'ils restent je sens qu'il
va rester moi j il ya une rumeur quand
même persistante c'est que zidane bien
aux parisiens et sa commande mais j'ai
eu quelques infos comme quoi ce serait
pour impossible mais j'ai choisi
d'aménager des infos vraiment de gens
qui sont dans le sud du côté de zidane
qui me dira corde alors j'espère ça
serait génial je pense que si zidane
mien je vois pas qu'il ya ne parvient
jamais ma vie voilà donc après j'y vois
là on espère que les deux seront là
[Musique]
si vous pensez tout savoir de la vie de
vos célébrités préférées ils sont tous
comme nous leur jardin secret leur
histoire de famille séparation famille
recomposée mais surtout enfants cachés à
nice qui se bat depuis des années pour
être reconnu par son père le chanteur
cheb khaled qui dément avoir quelconque
autre office mon seul et unique fils
d'high et moi vous souhaitons une bonne
année 2022 nous on a à nice avec nous tu
le fils du chantier rue khaled ou quand
vous aussi c'est votre seule votre maman
qui vous a dit que khaled était votre
votre papa oui ça après nous le dira
qu'elle rêvait et adaptés à l'âge de 26
ans d'accord à quel âge vous lui bat
depuis ma naissance j'ai envie de me l'a
jamais caché en soit des photos j'ai
apporté justement oui je peux me dit ma
mère que c'est une groupie d'accord je
suis lent 95 ses écrits de sa main 91
abonnés voilà des des souvenirs de ma
mère et de mon père qui vivait ensemble
amoureusement d'accord qui m'ont vu dans
un amour véritable et de ce que ma mère
m'a dit jusqu'à maintenant est décédé
depuis trois ans
il y avait des contacts au début en fait
ils étaient prêts à venir me voir de
temps en temps etc voilà et puis du jour
au lendemain en fait c'est comme si
j'avais été rayé de sa vie c'est à dire
que bah déjà j'avais pas été reconnu il
a fallu faire une lourde bataille
judiciaire que ma mère a mené avec brio
d'ailleurs
on a fait des tests adn ça salivaire
constaté par le juge vient alors à
partir de ce moment là j'ai porté son
nom j'ai été reconnue vous avait-il
reconnu la wii c'est ça mais d'ailleurs
souvent il ya méprise là dessus mais
j'ai eu c'est bien que vous leur disiez
vous avez été vous a été reconnue vous
êtes bien le fils de khaled c'est ça
mais qui grave en fait actuellement
c'est que ben j'aimais mes soeurs en
fait qui m'ont qui ont réussi à me
contacter et enfin certes elle l'a la
plus grande sarah elle m'avait contacté
au début j'en tu as une voix un peu
comme dans scream sur mon téléphone
après les articles web donne ton de
famine moi je le dois nettoyer là
j'entends une voix toute douce ouais bah
écoutes je ta soeur moi j'habite avec
eux
et puis elle m'a parlé des maltraitances
qu'elle subissait de sa mère et c'est
vrai que là j'ai jamais appris mon
existence en fait je cours et que bas
elle m'a donné une adresse du coup un
rendez vous qui l'avez lui avec sa femme
du coup ma belle-mère que j'embrasse
aussi d'ailleurs d'accord et
et là j'arrive je le croise dans la rue
j'ai eu des sales usa et lui dit je te
connais pas il est qu'elle sait très
bien ce wiki et 30 secondes après ce
mets à m'insulter à parler comme la
dernière des racailles ou laura moye
m'insulte de tous les noms ma maman moi
même on sent chez vous une grande
souffrance et ça lui est très difficile
de se construire avec ça mais il ya eu
un jugement vous avez été reconnue est
ce que dans le jugement le droit de
porter le nom y'a pas d'autres
obligations d'un père dans ces cas là
par exemple de vous voir
alors il ya des obligations financières
qui la remplit d'ailleurs je sais pas
voilà bien ce n'est pas lui qui les a
remplis pour être exact c'est sa maison
de disques ya jamais eu un revirement de
sa part c'est la sacem qui envoyait des
chacun la mer et
ouais c'est à peu près tous
d'accord là aussi c'est un grand pays
avec un énorme territoire de 17,5
millions de kilomètres carrés ouais donc
territoire ça m'intéresse pas notre pays
pauvres ça n'intéresse pas et alors vous
savez pourquoi il a la garde
économiquement la russie c'est un tout
petit pays avec le pib de portugal mais
ça veut dire que en fait ils ont s'il
n'avait pas l'arsenal nucléaire s'il y
avait de l'union soviétique personne lui
parlerai ne sont là que la question je
vous la pose aussi à vous qui voyez une
troisième guerre mondiale et que les la
france qui interviennent les états unis
que la chine prenne apprennent fatigue
aussi mort pour pour les russes c'est
possible ou pas on est à ça on a ça on
est à ça donc c'est 6 ils ont bombardé
ce matin les vifs les vives c'est à 50
km de la frontière polonaise je vous ai
montré bien sûr
derrière la frontière c'est l'union
européenne et le temps si un seul un
soldat de l'otan qui traversent la
frontière c'est la troisième guerre
mondiale les gars vous préparez un
préparez vous arriverez à huy fait ça
mais vous êtes inquiet je suis très
inquiet j'ai une source au kremlin qui
m'a expliqué il ya trois mois sur ma
chaîne youtube ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à meaux pour mon visa plein
de sons qui le disaient même bien plus
que trois mois il ya des gens
aujourd'hui un nom il ya quelques années
lapin blanc qui disait ça va se passer
et ce sera le début de la troisième
guerre mondiale vous savez ce qu'il m'a
dit ce matin
poutine il est capable aujourd'hui ou
demain ou après-demain faire exploser
une bombe à une kilotonnes juste pour
vous montrer ou jusqu'où il peut aller
c'est ça c'est pas un dégâts énormes
mais symboliquement vous et vous
imaginez la dernière fois il y aurait
jamais et nagasaki cette nuit lui
pourrait avoir recours à la matière que
vous l'avez dit il à la moitié de
l'arsenal nucléaire la planète est
d'accord ce qui se passerait la fin du
monde est la fin du monde ou simplement
il ya pire que vous soyez venus ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]